when you reach a certain level of wealth
you start to feel like nothing can touch
you you spit sunshine and crap gold at
least that's been my experience can't
imagine any of you can relate but please
allow me to explain how it feels when
there's three commas in your bank
balance i know time is money but don't
worry i'm good for it or at least i
thought i was before that night point is
the more money you get the higher you
climb that golden ladder the stronger
the feeling of security gets money can't
buy happiness or so the saying goes but
trust me when i say that it can buy
everything else and that's pretty close
that's right i'm one of the dreaded one
percent a straight-up billionaire baby
don't get me wrong i'm not some guy who
was born with a silver spoon in my mouth
i worked hard i was lucky of course and
i had some help from my parents but who
didn't get a little help from their
families while growing up after my dad
helped me get into an ivy league school
and gave me a 20 million loan as a
graduation present i was completely on
my own i scraped and i saved and i
turned that loan into the biggest tech
conglomerate in the entire world after i
made my first hundred million i stopped
worrying about being successful enough
driven enough good enough after my first
billion i felt like i could do anything
and honestly
i could the money stopped feeling real
stop being anything except a number
ticking ever upward and signifying that
i would never run out of points in the
game of life i'd won i purchased myself
a rocket with a velvet interior for
luxury space travel i filled the room in
my house with vintage guitars that had
all previously been touched by members
of the beatles just because i could i
moved into a cottage in tuscany a house
in martha's vineyard a beach house in
hawaii my los angeles mansion and my
favorite avila in the south of france
that's not all of them of course but
those are my top five if you ever get
the chance to have a house on every
continent i highly recommend it
just kidding i know most people won't
get the chance but maybe if you're lucky
you'll get an invitation to one of my
legendary parties if you're luckier than
lucky you'll find yourself with an
invitation to my annual costume party it
is an incredible spectacle every year
and this year was no exception picture
it me my beautiful wife and
international supermodel thank you very
much and a few hundred of our closest
friends gathered at my house nestled
right up against the french riviera the
theme was masquerade ball and the dress
code was strict no one would be admitted
without a mask or a tire elegant enough
for the party inside what greeted them
was nothing short of absolute opulence i
instructed my party planner to spare no
expense the ballroom was outfitted with
a massive swarovski chandelier thousands
of candles lighting the room flames
sparkling in the crystal and filling the
room with warm light in the corner a
string quartet borrowed from the
national opera of paris played next to
one of the six count them six champagne
fountains i commissioned a portrait of
me and my wife dressed to the nines and
wearing our masks and hung it in the
entryway to greet my guests in the
dining room guests could sit down to a
feast fit for louis xiv complete with 30
courses including pheasant pate poached
pears whole roasted boar and other
dishes inspired by the palace of
versailles for partygoers with more
modern palettes the molecular gastronomy
room was open with a chef on site to
serve flavored foams and vaporized
cocktails or those who wanted to stick
to the ballroom could enjoy the past
around hors d'oeuvres but really why
choose if they wanted they could have a
bit of everything or a lot of it money
was truly no object the party was going
great i was wearing my favorite suit
which cost more than most people spend
on a house and a custom designed mask
made from hundreds of black and white
diamonds with a few red diamonds thrown
in for a pop of color and because
they're the rarest variety of diamond in
the world the more you know right my
guests had all arrived and guards were
stationed at all entrances to make sure
no party crashers tried to make their
way inside and take advantage of my
hospitality and generosity so imagine my
surprise when long after the guest list
had been completely checked off a
mysterious figure swept in and
interrupted everything
my wife elbowed me in the side as i was
helping myself to some beluga caviar who
is that she hissed to me tilting her
head towards the doorway at the other
end of the ballroom i turned expecting
to see a foreign dignitary or an oil
baron she had forgotten the name of but
instead i saw something much more
bizarre there standing like a shadow in
the room full of silk and gold was a
person dressed in thick black robes they
were wearing a mask but it was
unsettling to look at intense dark eyes
peered out of the pale ceramic that
tapered into a long pointed beak i dimly
remember drawings of medieval doctors
wearing masks like those as the black
plague decimated europe this was just
some edgy party crasher looking for
attention i knew that but looking at
them a chill ran up my spy how did he
get in i shook my head motioning to one
of the security guards stationed near
the entrance do your job fellas come on
rob my beefiest guard got the signal and
approached the crasher i took a sip of
my drink eager to watch this wannabe
cool guy get booted from my world he
watched rob come closer as he stood
completely still little black eyes
unblinking what was this guy's steel he
reached out one black loved hand and
touched rob's throat with one finger as
soon as the stranger touched his skin
rob dropped to the ground unmoving he
was all the way on the other side of the
room but somehow i just knew he was dead
as soon as rob fell the party came to a
screeching halt my wife screamed and
tugged on my arm but i couldn't take a
step i just watched frozen in place as
the stranger in the plague doctor mask
pulled a syringe from a pocket in his
robes and injected something thick and
black into rob's corpse what had just
been a mound of dead flesh began to
thrash around hands grasping at nothing
legs kicking and something that looked
like rob but was definitely not him
climbed to its feet it had his face his
body but its eyes were hollow and dead
there was no light behind them they were
just flat the thing that once was raw
began to shuffle into the room the
stranger trailing behind it as he walked
he touched guests with his gloved hands
like rob they dropped to the ground
dead at a single touch guests began to
scatter in every direction running for
their lives still i couldn't get myself
to move a dozen people were dead on the
floor then two dozen then three as he
walked the stranger injected them with
more of the strange liquid and the dead
guests shambled to their feet or dragged
themselves along the floor with stiff
pale fingers the shuffling corpses that
were once my friends grabbed guests near
them with inhuman strength as they tried
to run away dragging them toward the
horrible doctor so he could kill and
transform them too i had to make a break
for it i had to get out of there but my
legs wouldn't listen to me fear and
morbid curiosity froze me to the spot
there had to be at least 50 zombies by
now and the doctor just kept going he
was getting closer and closer to me hand
outstretched and ready to deliver its
deadly touch i unstuck my tongue from
the roof of my mouth swallowed and spoke
why are you doing this the doctor paused
tilting his head to the side and thought
this home is overrun with the pestilence
it is my duty to contain its spread and
treat the infected he spoke formally in
a voice that reverberated from inside
the mask with a metallic edge they must
be cured i had to think fast i could
talk my way out of this i've sold
companies made mergers avoided paying
taxes my whole life now i just had to
negotiate for my own life my friends
might be gone but i at least could save
myself you're you're a doctor i said he
seemed pleased at this i am a physician
yes he said you're trying to help i
continued yes i see you two are a man of
science he had stopped coming closer the
zombies had stopped advancing on me it
was working i don't know if you're aware
of this but i am a very wealthy man
doctor i took a drink of my champagne
doing my best to appear casual friendly
even i'm sure you're in need of funding
for your mission perhaps we could work
together you wish to aid me in my
mission the doctor asked i do i lied i'm
in great health as you can see but i
don't want a
pestilence spreading around and
infecting me or my loved ones i'd like
to help you i paused searching for the
right words i could
be your patron the doctor clapped his
gloved hands together and i could have
sworn he smiled beneath his beaked
visage excellent this is the most
fortuitous meeting indeed i am glad to
have found you here sir if you would
come with me we may begin our work he
turned and swept out of the room
gesturing for me to follow i looked
around for an exit route a way to make a
break for it but there were too many
corpses ready to grab me with inhuman
strength and drag me to certain death
the room was filled with them shuffling
about in their torn formal wear slack
and jaws hanging loose and hollow eyes
watching me i had no choice but to
follow this guy and just wait for my
opportunity to get away i don't know how
long we walked down the narrow town
streets in the dark every time we passed
an alley i thought i could duck down the
doctor got closer to me with his deadly
hands or a group of zombies encircled me
i was outside i should have been home
free but there was nowhere to run
eventually the doctor stopped in front
of an abandoned dilapidated house the
paint was peeling off the walls and
there was a hole that rotted through the
ceiling welcome sir to my laboratory he
made a grand sweeping gesture inviting
me to walk through the door i obeyed
crossing the threshold the smell of rod
and dried blood hit me so hard that i
thought i might throw up the house was
dark i had to squint to sea but i could
make out scattered piles of body parts
animal and human there was a table
covered with surgical equipment and next
to it a black leather doctor's bag there
were people in here too or they used to
be people they were silent zombies like
the others some stood along the walls at
silent attention others were lying on
the ground hooked up to ivs full of
strange liquid where strapped to
gurney's ready to be operated on
ah
this this looks great my voice shook but
i hoped he wouldn't notice
with my funds we can upgrade your lab
get you to a more high-tech facility
better lighting more space research
assistance excellent together we will
eradicate the pestilence once and for
all there the doctor pointed at the
medical table to my right grab a pair of
gloves and slide them on the doctor
nodded as i squeezed my hands into a
pair of rubber medical gloves
absolutely can you show me more of what
you're working on good thinking when his
back was turned i would run out the door
and get to safety the doctor approached
the table covered with tools and bent to
pick up a scalpel now was my moment i
ran toward the door as fast as my legs
would carry me i collided with something
hard and cold it was rob my old
bodyguard doing what he did best keeping
the perimeter secure sir
where are you going the doctor called
are you
trying to abandon
our work he paused for a moment
realizing what i had done did you
deceive me
his voice turned cold angry no no no i
i couldn't come up with a lie rob
wrapped his arms around my chest holding
me in place as the doctor approached me
with the scalpel in hand you are not
looking well my friend perhaps you have
fallen ill such a shame i'd look forward
to our collaboration he drew the scalpel
stretching his hand out towards my neck
i thrashed around arms flailing and
grabbing at his mask with gloved hands
what did this monster look like
underneath who was he what was he the
mask did not budge and i realized this
was no mask it was his face don't worry
his blade sliced into the side of my
neck i will make you well again his
black eyes twinkled as he set to work
then everything went dark now go check
out scp-049 the plague doctor captured
and
scp-049 what actually is the pestilence
the plague doctor questions and theories
for more stories of this not so good
doctor